this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
army's museum in the uk which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this episode jonathan's back with the
call of duty franchise this time taking
a look at the weapons from modern
warfare 2 remastered i'm not quite sure
why the teddy bear has the gold deagle
and i hate myself for saying this but
this is a really nice rendition of a
gold design
if you want to see jonathan's take on
call of duty boy have we got a lot of
videos for you make sure to check our
back catalogue with those you can find a
link to our playlist in the description
of this video and if you enjoy this kind
of content make sure to keep an eye out
for our new series loadout a show we
take a look at the history and impact of
some of the most iconic weapons in
gaming from the m1 garand and the desi
eagles through to the minigun and the
ak-47 naturally jonathan will be making
a fair few appearances over on that show
too so make sure to check it out right
let's take a look at modern warfare 2
remastered
[Music]
the venerable m4 m4a1 it's another one
of these uh m4s that isn't actually an
m4 well
sort of so the the original modern
warfare 2m4 had a of a not m4 barrel
profile it was something like a m653 or
something pencil barrel as they're
called and then it did have this very
weird rail system hand guard with the
with the vented portion between the rail
and the actual hand guard if i remember
rightly this was taken from an airsoft
replica that wasn't a faithful replica
of the m4 which is
why it's ended up in the game and it
doesn't actually look exactly like an
m4a1 should so what should an m4a1 look
like well one upgrade they have made to
this model
is the m4 barrel profile this isn't
actually an m4 either by the way i'll
explain that in a minute but the barrel
is the correct
profile so it's the 14 and a half inch
barrel and it has this uh it's the thick
m16a2 barrel profile so so better for
accuracy
but to accommodate the m203 grenade
launcher what they had to do was keep
this section reduce diameter so that's
where you get that distinctive notch in
the barrel that is distinctive of the m4
and m4 a1 anything that doesn't have a
14.5 inch barrel with that cut on it is
not an m4 or an a1 so what am i going on
about in terms of this not being an m4
well it's the closest thing we have in
the collection right now to an m4 the
only external difference that you the
eagle eyed would spot is this flash
hider flash suppressor which is an a1
style not an a2 style but actually if
you were to take a micrometer to this
and look at all of the details you'd
realize this is not actually
a usgi m4 differs in various respects
including having england written on the
side because this is actually
made for a british company so it's an
interesting piece of firearms history
but not strictly an m4 but that's okay
because neither is modern warfare 2's
rifle
i think it might be worth talking
briefly about automatic versus
semi-automatic fire because this bit of
footage here we do get a good sense here
of the bullet the amount of dispersion
of shot of bullets on target at this
distance it's quite yeah using a mouse
or whatever you're using but it's it's
relatively hard to control versus the
sort of fire that we see a little bit
after that with rapid semi-automatic
fire and that is now standard in
militaries around the world it's
actually very similar to what you see in
the game whether you're pulling a
trigger on a controller or tapping a
mouse button or pulling a trigger on a
real gun the thing just moves around
less you know you can train to shoot
very very rapidly semi-automatic and the
effective rate of fire is not 700 rounds
per minute or whatever but it's far more
economical in terms of ammunition you're
far more likely to hit what you're
aiming at at any kind of distance it's
funny that even a game like call of duty
that is not yeah it's got a realistic
kind of veneer but it doesn't purport to
be a military simulator or anything it's
funny that even a game like that it can
be more effective to not use automatic
fire but it's almost never as fun
now the 1887 which has always irked me
in modern warfare it's about the
furthest thing you could get from from
modern warfare in terms of hardware but
it's a fun gun to use nonetheless in the
game and actually i think they've done a
really good job of modeling this you
know you can look at details and
nitpick as i sometimes do but i'm gonna
give it a bit of a pass even the way
it's opened up there to top off which
you can do obviously with a tube fed
weapon like this i guess it's the only
advantage for me that this weapon ever
had in multiplayer was you didn't have
to time your your magazine reloads you
could just thumb in some extra
cartridges and be a bit more prepared
the only other thing i'd say about the
1887 is that i'm happy they didn't tack
to cool it the only the only concession
to a vaguely modern iteration of the
design are the sort of combat
pistol combat style sights that are on
there which on the on the original
winchester 1887 well there aren't any
sights
there's a
shallow groove on the receiver and
lining up the muzzle with that is all
you need for effectively instinctive
shooting or close range
shooting but hey if you like your
winchester 1887 this is probably the
best iteration of it feel free to argue
that
one on the left
[Music]
i i don't know i think this might be
where the first sign of modern warfare
drifting toward sci-fi warfare i think
someone probably read the original
rainbow six novel where they literally
had heartbeat censored which i think tom
clancy based on some rescue fire
fighting equipment that could detect
something through a wall um that's
clearly gone nowhere since then and he
extrapolated this to be literally like a
magic box that could see things through
walls modern warfare 2 turned it into a
weapon mounted
accessory which meant mounting a piece
of picatinny rail to the side of the
receiver just something you wouldn't
normally do
fun gameplay but if you're if you're
nerdy about guns like me it was a bit
off-putting now the masada was licensed
to remington
bushmaster depending on whether you're
going to buy the select fire version or
the civilian semi-automatic version and
turned into the advanced combat rifle
the acr and this is a relatively early
example from our collection interesting
little detail
and full disclosure dave spotted this
this is the magpul pmag now when the
character
is inspecting the rifle if you look
closely
that magazine is hanging almost all the
way out of the gun when it should be
all the way into the gun
what you're seeing there the little
notch that's just shy of the the lip of
the magazine well is actually
part of the magazine catch system the
magazine catch engages into that notch
finer detail but we like to spot those
things on here
let's get to that
ak-47 what is it
sort of is the answer it is a mash-up
and it's modernized appropriately for a
modern warfare game so the milled
receiver is combined with various
features of akm sheet metal version of
the ak so it's kind of like the main two
variants if you like the classic mold
receiver ak and the stamp cheap receiver
akm
k became the ak-74 the ak-100 series
it's got features of both now there are
foreign countries foreign countries to
russia that is that produce ak variants
that are something of a mishmash but
they usually stick to one or the other
pattern for the various components what
i'm getting at is that russia does not
no longer produces machined receiver
collational clocks they've moved over
entirely to the to the stamp receiver
type and so this being the main weapon
of the russians in the game wasn't
realistic when the original game was
released and of course it still isn't on
the most fundamental level when the
russians are using it it's the wrong
completely the wrong gun and if you look
at it in detail it is a sort of weird
parts kit build of different types
of ak
something something is um sticking out
for me here with the with the org or aug
whichever you prefer the original modern
warfare 2 version had like a rail carry
angle um like the
h bar behind me a side rail as it were
and then to that is attached whatever
optical sight you wish with the
remastered version they've reverted to
the integral carry handle scope mount of
the original aug which is kind of cool
it's got more of that classic die-hard
look to it but i think i'm right in
saying that that's resulted in it being
very high because originally you had
semiconductor mount and then you had a
version of the interpro optic that was
piggybacked on top of that that made the
height over bore of the site very tall
they seem to have kept that the height
of the optic and then just converted it
back to its old shape if that makes
sense so why is that a problem well if
it was a real gun
ideally you want a cheek weld you don't
want to chin well it's less stable
otherwise it's looking pretty good
perhaps better
in terms of accuracy to the original
model and of course the graphics on the
game are vastly improved the textures
are much much better but it's
interesting looking to see what's
changed over the original iteration of
the game they've just retextured or even
remodeled from scratch they have i think
completely recreated the whole all of
the all of the models from scratch and
that has
given them artistic license to
incorporate features that either weren't
there before or in this case to
eliminate features that were there
before
as i'm sure a lot of you will know the
mysteriously named intervention is
actually the the shaitak m 200 model now
we don't have any we have any shy attack
rifles in this collection so i can't
comment on the details of it looks good
to me it looks much improved as all the
graphics in the game are and it's lost
none of that sort of thump and the sort
of visceral experience of a rifle of
this nature which obviously modern
warfare 2 wasn't the first to do that by
any means but i think the the move from
from the barrett
which we've seen in other games to a
bolt action adds something it make it
makes it feel like each shot is counting
more and of course you have to make him
shot count a little more because you
can't just follow it up with the next
shot that's not a problem if for people
who use these things for real because
they're generally doing so from quite
some distance this is really not very
far away and that's not to say they're
not used at that distance but you'd
probably want a semi-automatic
rifle if you were having to fight with a
rifle like this but
i defer to the to the soldiers on that
one i've got to say this is a really
nice
representation of an absolutely
ludicrous weapon the desert eagle has
obviously it's appeared in countless
games at this point it's more of a star
of uh screen of one sort or another than
it will ever be a practical handgun but
there's just something about the thing
it's so it's so crazy it's huge the
recoil the sound the look of the thing
all captured really well here
particularly good sound effects i know
it's just the speakers i'm using today
but really sounds quite chunky the
recoil is not only significant but
controlled you know the the user clearly
has the the wrist strength to deal with
this thing but also the coils
convincingly up and to the right which
with a two-handed grip it will
tend to do shoot it one-handed which is
perfectly doable
it will like most pistols tend to recoil
up and left it's just to do with the
sort of biomechanics of how you grasp
the thing and of course it makes quite
the impression on the enemy as it ought
to 50 caliber rounds going some speed
weighing a fair bit
impacting with some force even if even
through uh soft body armor they're gonna
they're gonna make a serious impact
i'm not quite sure why the teddy bear
has the gold deagle and i hate myself
for saying this but this is a really
nice rendition of a gold design
they've captured the sort of the surface
finish and shine that you get with a
decently gold plated gun i can't believe
i'm being positive about a gold gun in a
game or even in real life for that
matter but um yeah hey if you're gonna
rock a gold eagle it may as well be this
one
fnfal
val if you prefer interesting little
details of the new models they've
created here so i think in the original
game there were either no rounds modeled
or something very basic when you took a
magazine out of the gun here we've got a
nicely modeled sheet metal magazine and
we've got one two three visible rounds
maybe there are four in there but then
we can see it what looks like a follower
now this is supposed to be a full
magazine but it's only actually loaded
in the game world with maybe four rounds
now it's super harsh of me to look at
this in this freeze frame detail we're
trying to replicate the full mechanics
of a firearm for a game well ideally
you'd want to model the spring you'd
want all the rounds in there of course
practically speaking there's rarely a
need to do
all of that but they are they've really
come on
in modelling things like bolts rounds
and mags things like that so again i'm
being extremely critical
the iconic famas here and i do believe
it's the proper representation rather
than the modern warfare 2019 version
with its weird gas system that was
grafted on for reasons that i don't
understand now more glaring than any of
that is all of that tape why does this
thing have so much tape on it now um
some of you know that i am not a fan of
bandaging and taping here though i think
what they're going for is taping as a
camouflage technique i'm not sure this
is the best job ever but this is a
somewhat valid technique that is done
now i think taping is is somewhat out of
fashion but the idea is to break up the
outline the silhouette and if you have
it as on this a flat black surface which
actually stands out quite badly this is
why you see so many brown and green
rifles now is because just plain black
actually can stand out quite badly
against certainly against a nicely
camouflaged person and against the
background so you need to break up that
silhouette i think that's what this is
doing or maybe they have copied maybe
they've used reference of a photo of the
guy with a taped-up rifle for arctic
type training and have sort of done a
version of that that maybe isn't as
taped as it ought to be
[Applause]
it's times like this when i see someone
having a whale of a time with dual
wielded mini oozies very nicely rendered
as well i might say nice high rate of
fire times like this i think call of
duty should just lean into the action
movie thing fully rather than sort of
pretending to be a serious military
shooter which it can be sometimes and
do something straight out of an action
movie you know when i see when i see
something like this that's just not
something a soldier would almost never
do
i think we'd be better off in a more of
a
an action
scenario of course we get the the
dubious off-screen reload because how
would you actually reload these well you
wouldn't if you're going to do a full-on
action movie game you would just have
you would just fight until their empty
and throw them throw them to the ground
pick up more weapons i have a criticism
of these mini uzis
it's the
case ejection it's a little old school
it's coming out very slowly very
sideways
really kind of early 2000s first person
shooter they should really be flying out
quite a steep angle quite hard spinning
through the air as they go
looking
there
forward
[Music]
so
don't get pinned down out there keep
heading for the runway area
okay that's a nice touch i'm so looking
at an rpd here and i was thinking
how are they going to deal with that
picatinny rail mount so they've got a
system here with a pivoting
side rail so the character has to pivot
the rail out of the way before we can
then lift the top cover to reload
the machine gun as you would normally
reload a machine gun so they've actually
thought about how this system is working
they've gone for a side mount as a
russian design tradition rather than a
rail fixed to the top cover now that
probably would have been the way to go
but it does give us a little bit of
interesting variety in how
the gun has to be operated and it
slightly delays your reloading animation
which may or may not be significant
so as it proclaims on the side of this
rifle we have a mark 17 mod zero perhaps
us navy terminology for the f and scar
so ours is in fact marked with the fn
markings
fn hostile belgium scar h
cal 760 by 51
this thing has
special operations command markings
basically so it's obviously it's a
service version this is a commercial
version and i mean commercial in the
sense that it's not for issue to a
specific military it is select fire has
the same
selector as
the one in the game does interestingly
the one in the game has much more
prominent circle circular depressions
around the um a for automatic the one
for single shot semi-automatic
and the s for safe presumably although i
can't see that in this view this is much
more flushed i don't know if that's a
production change over time but i can
see that there's a heck of a lot of
detail on this model this is really very
close to the real thing we've even got
the little grub screw in the back of the
selector
there
good job on this one
[Applause]
not a bad hmk ump45
except that it's not an hdk ump45 it's
an s m the ump45
schmidt and maya is what's actually
written on the side of the quite nicely
rendered polymer receiver there
amusingly
the serial number which should be on a
metal part of the receiver on the side
of the gun appears here in one garand
style on the back of the receiver so in
your within your field of view as a
player it says s n for serial number and
then it says it sort of in in leet speak
or a mixture of letters and numbers
mctavish which is a reference that if
you don't get you probably shouldn't be
watching this video
another marking on the gun
is a real marking and increasingly
common has been since i guess the late
90s and that is markings like refer to
owner's manual which is what's on the
side of this gun that is not some sort
of
joke that is
literally what's written on quite a few
firearms these days health and safety is
just as important when you're dealing
with firearms perhaps more so than other
consumer products and legally speaking
companies are obliged to put warnings
like that now i'm not sure that a
a military issue firearm won't won't say
refer to owner's manual um they're not
bound by the same legal requirements but
hey this is
this is a fictional and b has probably
been purchased for some sort of
off-the-shelf special operations
who knows
join us again next time of course uh
we've also got videos on the royal
armouries youtube channel that you might
well want to check out a bit more of a
historical dive into
guns in general other arms and armor
that are on that channel as well and we
have our own social media of course the
museums if you can visit
events going on as well and if you feel
moved to do so we'd appreciate a
donation as well thanks guys take care
[Music]
you